the Joe Rogan experience there's uh
there's one other video oh yeah this
right here look at this
sharpshooters of these little mice they
put mice in the middle of the village
and they shoot down with bows and arrows
yep um that seems mean I mean he got
reduce eat them yeah yeah the UNAM so
that's their target practice so they
show grass grass I've that's a rat by
the way a mouse yeah they'd shoot these
rats and then they eat them yep
and actually not this one you eatin
right I have for stuff like not good
it's finished stringy I've had I've had
Python I've had Cobra you a Cobra
I've had monkey I think I'm thank you
that's dark is there is there a video of
the kid with the machete what's it like
eating monkey does that freak you out
eat one your ancestor this was right
before the Ebola breakup oh I didn't
know about it and then also an Ebola and
they're like it's from eating monkeys oh
Jesus I think y'all tell me kid a bola
we always eat monkeys none of us have
ever had Ebola what kind of what method
of cooking is it like a smoked monkey
just smoked it yeah wrap it a banana
leaf yeah it's a very like stringy hard
muscular animal yeah and my friend Steve
Rinella had some I think in Guyana
he uh he ate a monkey see this uh look
at this kid here he's with a machete
the machetes as long as that kid is tall
was he doing chopping down this tree I
just tried it on the tree for firewood
mmm but that kid looks like he's five
years old if that he's younger than that
I think how old well he might be five
maybe four four or five and they're
letting him use a machete to chop down a
[ __ ] tree because this kid climb the
trees with that the kid Lee came I saw
climb that tree he was doing that with
bows and arrows oh my god with bows and
arrows here so hard look here that's
just hanging out by him
tell us the kid is right next to him how
many of these guys that live in these
villages are injured uh I mean they get
injured from time to time yeah but
they're super smart with the blades I
mean they grow up without a mean throw
it's like getting a cut
I mean just injured injured there's no
medical man they roll their ankles
through the forest they when they're
climbing stuff need ligaments yeah what
do they wind up doing
they just heal he a lot like by giving
it rest what's kind of cool about the
forest life or the village life is they
literally they are up early
right when the sun's coming up they're
they're up they're down when the Sun
Goes Down and so they're in tune with
nature get out when the circadian
rhythms was looking for it yeah and then
midday during the heat of the day right
3:00 to 5:00 p.m.
they're normally just chillin napping or
in their Hut to where they're out of the
Sun and so they're up working before
that they rest and if they need to go
back out before the sun's down they go
back out a second time hunting gathering
come back in prepare it what's that
primary look what are they trying to
hunt well uh so for us antelope Forest
hog or wild hog out there lots of
different kinds of birds parrots
different things like that only using
bows and arrows
mhm home hidden bows now's right
homemade yeah definitely in the
dangerous ones I'm gonna have to bring
you a bow and arrow I haven't done that
I have one that is that I really love
I'll see if I can get to get you one but
they will give you two arrows one has a
metal blade and one's just a sharpened
tip and then they ask you which one
would you use on an antelope and you
choose which one you you choose and then
you ask which one would you use on a
bird and then you choose which one would
you think between a blade and the
sharpened wood which one would you use
on the antelope you'd use a blade okay
and then on a bird which one would you
sharpened stick yeah that's what makes
sense to our mind right yeah it's
actually the opposite how come they use
the metal on the bird because that's
going to kill the bird right they use
the wooden tip because they they dip
that in poison oh geez and so that's
what they take the bigger animals out
with as I say so they just have to hit
it oh yeah anywhere in its body and it's
in there now does that poison infect
them no they eat it looks out it's out
of this there's these two things these
berries in the
not roots but it's a like a root fruit
like a potato it's this poisonous black
potato that like they mash up and if you
if you mess with that stuff the potato
gets smashed or something in that oil or
that whatever casaba noxious ABBA
because the cassava Savas root but also
is gets strychnine yeah you have to boil
it forever they have to do all this [ __ ]
the cassava and then that the I know yes
and this it's a black potato no they use
the strychnine from cassava to poison
things as well Wow and they have like a
bucket Brunell is show Steven I will
show the meat eater which is on it is on
Netflix and no the mediator is his
website meat eater is a Netflix show but
he went to Guyana and she's done a
couple trips to different I think
Bolivia as well and when you goes to the
jungle like this they have this
incredibly intricate process for cooking
and making this cassava edible and these
buckets they have of this sort of
process stuff as they're doing it is
[ __ ] hugely toxic yeah and it's just
laying around
yeah and my kids are playing there it
and the the kids have to be so careful
yeah the parents have to be so careful
with the poison yeah because once they
dip those tips of those arrows they
don't come back with them they dispose
of them really out in the fools just too
dangerous too dangerous to have around
the kids
the toddler's that are oh yeah cuz
toddlers are walking around with those
and arrows already there they have a bow
and arrow before they're able to walk so
they're just the sharpened wooden tips
without the poison dip down
[Applause]